make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so originally I was gonna cover
x-men vol 2 alright as x-men issue
number two rather but then I forgot the
blackest night was coming out the tails
mid arc multiverse story so we've got to
cover that so again picking up with this
what this does is essentially give us a
recap of the events of blackest night
now we have covered that so if you want
the full totality of what happened in
Green Lantern blackest night check the
playlist that I have down in the
description it runs from the beginning
of a Green Lantern rebirth explains all
kinds of stuff running all the way up
until we get to get to blackest night
and brightest day and I think we sort of
wore the Green Lantern's and then we
need to finish that but this story is
amazing so the way this worked out and
this really centers around the character
of Doug and I want to talk about this
for a second right because for donned
Rangers she was an interesting character
Don Granger had this ability where she
could turn into dev if she was in the
presence of danger right but if there
was no actual danger there that she
wouldn't transform the reason why this
matters is because in the events of the
original blackest night ah that was kind
of the big prophecy right the power of
prophecy of blackest night that
essentially like the Black Lantern
really the black man to an entity nekron
would return and he would basically
start resurrecting all these dead
superheroes now the reality of blackest
night in DC comics is it was designed
this would be like a soft reboot of
source right blackest night and
brightest day play the scenario whereby
blackest night would resurrect every
single dead superhero brightest day
would only keep the ones DC wanted right
that white lanterns could basically
return them back to normal and so the
issue with that is all right not really
the issue but the idea that came out of
that is a lot of superheroes return but
then a lot of other superheroes die and
it was basically it kind of sucked for
some fans because it was basically DC
saying like your favorite superheroes
not popular enough to keep alive which
kind of stings to be honest it stings a
little bit but that was the overall gist
of it the kicker about this is it part
way through the story
dov had basically kind of emitted this
white light to basically shut down black
Lantern's right essentially just
defeated them and destroyed them and
initially it wasn't really explained as
to how it was a she was able to do that
at least not until we got to blackest
night number three and then with Barry
Allen witnessing the whole thing go down
he came to the realization that Dov was
channeling the white light of creation
which is the way in which you defeat
black Lantern's
so that's why this matters is because
during that scenario once you got into
blackest night the only way to win was
to create white lanterns and because
Sinestro became the first one and the
original story Sinestro shared his White
Lantern
and ultimately the black lanterns were
essentially destroyed and this one the
way this played out is that ultimately
he didn't do that instead of sharing his
power as his white lanterns with the
other superheroes of Earth instead he
kept it for himself and the result was
that ultimately he wasn't powerful
enough to defeat necron on his own and
ultimately Necron ended up winning out
the Black Lantern is basically killed
pretty much all the other superheroes on
earth and even Sinestro kind of turned
the ring on himself and tried to take
himself out and this is where the story
basically picks up because what it does
is it ends up showing up with Lobo in
San Francisco now I'll be honest with
you guys what a great way to start a
story I love Lobo
I love Lobo because he's just basically
DC's character who just doesn't care
which is kind of cool but at the end of
the day Lobo was a bounty hunter and
ultimately he was sent here for the
character of death and the reason why
dove has been able to survive for so
long is again because of this white
light of creation as she channels
ultimately she's been able to keep the
black Lantern's at bay and so as a
result of this Lobo shows up and
basically starts taking out these
various like lanterns and then
ultimately ends up coming across
Sinestro or at least al Sinestro shows
now this is where things get kind of
finicky because Sol Sinestro is one half
black Lantern and one half white Lantern
basically the white lantern kind of
keeps him alive but the Black Lantern
wing is or at least the the death aspect
is always trying to take him out so he's
kind of stuck between life and death but
what you end up doing is basically
picking up with him using the white
Lantern ring to try to not necessarily
resurrect heroes or to fix heroes but
ultimately to kind of buy them some time
and the reason why is because at this
point the way it's indicated here is we
can go one of two ways
either we can say the white Lantern ring
or at least let the black Lantern's are
too far along to be saved permanently
meaning they can't basically be cured of
the Black Lantern or at least the Black
Lantern re infection or the the power
the Sinestro has with regards to
wielding the white light of creation
isn't strong enough and we could
probably go with the second one the
recently just not strong enough as a
white Lantern to basically fix black
lanterns to cure them which sort of
makes sense given everything that's gone
on here but when the questions asked why
it is that that Lobos here Lobo
basically says I was tasked with like
like hiring this this chick and bringing
her and then taking her to another
location now this is where things get
kind of interesting right because
remember when a can't the events of
blackest night that yes ground zero was
in effect earth but it's spread
throughout the universe like at a rapid
pace right like he was moving in a very
very fast clip that was the idea
of blackest night that like the entire
universe would be engulfed in darkness
so like everything would basically fall
and so everyone everywhere who's died
has been resurrected by a Black Lantern
ring so if you're talking about the Dead
Rising astronomically the difference
here is that we are talking about
nineteen days we're also talking about
the time it takes for rings to get out
there four rings to land and dibond on
people to resurrect them and so on so
forth so it's still a process is kind of
ongoing and that's one of the cool
things about this is yes we're 19 days
into the events of blackest night and
people are still being resurrected by
Black Lantern rings because so many
people have died as a result of this
Sinestro doesn't really consider Earth
to be a lost cause so much as the answer
is he's seeking on how to eliminate the
Black Lantern ring infection don't
really reside here the only thing that
that really seems to have an answer is
duh but even thought Sinestro doesn't
know exactly what's going on with her he
knows it's the white light of creation
but aside from that he doesn't really
know how it all works and so getting
together with Lobo and then grabbing
Doug and leaving Earth and heading out
to their location really is done by
Sinestro because in his mind at least he
can get an answer out of it all here's
one of the funny things that that that
goes on with this is Thal Sinestro
really starts to talk about the black
Lantern's and the idea is that in in the
mind of false Sinestro while the black
Lantern's represent death which is
technically not part of the emotional
spectrum then its wielders are using the
emotional spectrum that these threads
these tethers that really kind of
reached out and pulled them from death
and back into life were predicated on
emotions that they felt when they did
die right so like hatred for an enemy or
love for an ally or for a family member
or something like that
that's what anchors and that's what
keeps them there so there's still part
and parcel to the emotional spectrum but
technically the black reign of black
Lantern's are not really an emotional
spectrum at all but once a group arrives
at a cron gauchos things kind of go awry
now here's the important thing to
understand here takron-galtos has a
history in DC Comics right it originally
appeared in adventure comics number 359
this is basically a prison planet is
essentially what this is right as a
prison planet that's been used by the
guardians of the universe is a prison
planet that's been used by lobo to
basically drop people off it's designed
for high-security prisoners the reason
why I mention this and the reason why
this is important is because when
Sinestro and Dov and Lobo basically
starts scanning this planet for signs of
life or what-have-you they basically see
a whole bunch of energy signatures but
the temperatures are low which indicate
black Lantern's this is important
because what it means is this prison
planet home to some of the most
dangerous criminals throughout the
entirety of the known galaxy and even
the universe
have all been turned into black lanterns
these include characters like granny
goodness he's include characters like
big Barda like these are basically
individuals who work for Darkseid right
like big Barda was one of the Furies one
of the the female personal henchmen of
Darkseid himself as well as granny
goodness who trained them these are not
weak people the problem is that when
they get here there's just so many of
them that's so literally like once again
and you have Scott free mr. miracle
who's just like fleeing for his life and
he's just like run that way just run and
keep going and this is important because
one of the things of Scott free talks
about is how he basically been going
from like cell to cell right basically
trying to hide out an escape from the
various members of the Black Lantern
rings but the idea here is that
ultimately he reached out to dove
because of the fact that what he
witnessed in terms of Dove using the
white light of creation and so on and so
forth she's the way in which this can be
defeated now again while Scott free is
probably the greatest escape artist in
the entirety of the universe one of the
other things about him is that he's also
exceedingly intelligent and exceedingly
cunning and so with him working
alongside them Sinestro does not dismiss
him but ultimately what you end up
getting here is basically Scott free
saying that because dove channels the
white light of creation and because the
white light of creation is capable of
curing the black Lantern's and and
basically removing the Black Lantern
infection that essentially scot-free has
come up with this idea and what he does
is he basically tells them about the
source water I feel like there's this
barrier around the universe with regards
to keeping it away from each universe
having its own and then around the
entirety of the of the multiverse as a
whole but the idea was to basically
break through the source wall and then
essentially find the white light of
creation right the source of all
creation and then use that source light
to basically eradicate everything in the
universe or let not really eradicate
everything but to eliminate the Black
Lantern infection now it's kind of a
cool thing because with Dove Bo really
channeling the white light of creation
what it basically says is that where
most individuals would see the source if
they even managed to get past the source
wall in the first place which almost
nobody ever does but if they were able
to get you to give basilosaurus wall and
see the source most individuals will be
driven insane right like just by the
power of creation the difference here is
that where most people would be consumed
and destroyed by that power dove is a
living conduit for that power right
she's like water and electricity it just
flows right through her and so because
of that she can basically channel the
source of the source energies of all
creation and then wipe out all the black
lanterns across the universe it's an
amazing idea
and for people who were fans of dove
it's kind of their chance to like stand
up and to be seen right because like
Jesus she's a character that I wouldn't
say it doesn't really get a whole lot of
love in DC but she's certainly a
character that depending on who you're
talking to certainly flies under under a
lot of people's different radars that's
almost a great moment for a character
because ultimately it's agreed upon yes
this is probably the best idea that we
have because you're talking about
channeling the light of creation itself
the problem is that when they get there
what's essentially gone on here is that
big Barda alongside like the other
lanterns on on earth have all basically
tracked into their location and so
literally using boom tubes they all just
come come cruising in right like they
all just come flying in and that's when
things really begin to pop off because
all these various forces here are all
being led by the avatar of Necron which
is darkside what you have here is a
Black Lantern darkside and can we just
say for a minute that a Black Lantern
darkside is amazing it looks so cool it
is amazing like I love the way he looks
it's amazing because the first thing he
does here is like he shows up and he
literally uses his own mega beams and
like seems to destroy lobo now he was
like here's a funny thing if so long as
a single cell of lobo exists he can
duplicate himself and so if that's the
case like literally lobo just comes back
right he just he just brings himself
right back and it just keeps happening
that way right like lobo just duplicates
himself over and over again so you've
got an army of lobos against all the
black Lantern's along with thousand str
doing the best he can now this is when
you get this amazing tall Sinestro
moment I'll bet you this point one of
the big things that fall Celestials kind
of been doing is you kind of you know
kind of been like okay let's focus on
the mission but you haven't really seen
the not really the softer side but the
more I guess human for lack of a better
word side of thoughts on issue he's not
really human but you know like the the
compassionate side of his of his
character and when he's confronted by
cirrhotic not to who's his biological
daughter as well as Hal Jordan
ultimately he uses his white Lantern
power for a second gates them back to
their normal cells and then just
apologizes and spills the beans and says
I'm sorry like I did what I did and I
fail and I doomed our universe to the
black Lantern's conquering everything if
I had done what I was supposed to and if
I had not let my pride get the better of
me then you guys would have been white
Lantern's and we would have saved all of
creation but I was a fool and I
destroyed everything that matters
this kind of heart light it's kind of
outpouring of sinestro it's something
that you don't really see that often in
DC comics and it's a good thing that you
don't because if you did that it would
it would take away from the impact so
the fact that you see it you know this
this little moment here the fact that
you see this is amazing because it shows
that al Sinestro is still a very complex
being and it's one of the coolest things
about his characters one of the best
things about his character he's not some
2-dimensional villain of the week
you see complexity and that's what
really drives and that's one of the
reasons why I say oftentimes the
villains are more interesting than the
heroes because if I said Hal Jordan next
mm sto and I said you know I had to
compare which one do I like the most Val
Sinestro every single time he's more
interesting he's more complex he's a
great character he's raised one of the
best characters in all of DC and so with
that being the case was essentially
happened here is a kind of harness has
been constructed for Doug in order for
her to basically harness the white light
of creation the funny thing about this
is that scott-free was never actually
told what would happen all he was told
is the source would be harnessed by Dove
in the deterrent she would quote-unquote
fix everything
what is up happening here is darkside
chimes in with the truth of the
situation which is confirmed by Thal
Sinestro that what's going to happen
here is that in this scenario the source
is going to wipe everything out it's
gonna wipe the entire universe out and
essentially reboot it right that's what
it's going to do and ultimately what
that would mean is of all the characters
as they seem to exist here now which
simply ceased to exist and the universe
would be started over again it'd be a
clean slate is what they refer to it as
and it's interesting because in that
moment what you end up having is
scott-free who says no like initially he
shuts it down because he's like I don't
want to do anything without big Barda
now initially it's really easy to
dismiss this and it's kind of people
okay so this is stupid you know but it
actually works because for people who
have been reading scott-free for a long
time who have been reading stories of
mr. miracle him and big Barda Archie
peas in a pod right like they're they're
one of the coolest couples in all of DC
Comics and really an entire books
depending on who's right in the story
and so with scott-free one having to
leave big Barda behind because of the
fact that she's a Black Lantern and then
to having to abandon any possibility of
saving her is more than he can handle
and so whatever I buy I love or
foolishness he ends up killing Duff he
ends up snapping her neck and he won't
let her basically wipe out everything
else across the universe and kind of
restart it all and what this does is it
almost seems to put into this
perspective the fact that like the black
Lantern's of one and this is when Thal
Sinestro gets his moment and this is why
let's see this is why I love Sinestro he
says yes I was arrogant and I was
foolish and I doomed the universe to
this mistake but I will not make the
same mistake twice
I will not screw up twice these are the
reason why is because Hal Jordan was
right I am the greatest Lantern that
there ever was I am the absolute best
I will reincarnate everyone and I will
basically I'm the linear avatar of life
I will not fail and so where he's unable
to saved of what he says is that because
lobo is able to basically duplicate
himself in such a way that lobo is
essentially a being that that's life
incarnate and so using lobo he basically
channels the power of the source through
lobo and in turn that goes through and
wipes out although all the black
lanterns and then also wipes out
everything else really kind of kind of
clean slates the entirety of the
universe and so following that what this
does is it sort of ghost forward in this
way where society begins to sort of
rebuild there's this kind of religion
this kind of societal perspective that
like lobo is kind of their god is really
sort of how they view them it's cool the
way this goes down the problem with this
is that unlike all these other
individuals out there who basically were
clean slitted restarted more or less
Thal Sinestro didn't experience any of
that he's watching all of this unfold
he's watching all this go down this
universe come into existence and where
he's trying to essentially escape and
what's now called the limbo Lantern
basically that's what he is now like
this Lancer this kind of stuck in limbo
between life and death where they called
the limbo Lantern and he's trying to
escape because the entire roll of
tempest fudgie not is to cordon off
these universes and make sure nothing
gets in and nothing gets out ultimately
thousand destro struggles against
resistance and can never leave his
universe but basically what you're
talking about here entails of the dark
multiverse is an entire universe that
was successfully conquered by the black
Lantern's and then it came down to maybe
a couple people who were able to
basically fix everything it's a cool
story unlike the other ones it doesn't
end on a dark note it doesn't end on the
note of light this is a-you number four
the black Lantern's won and everybody
ended up becoming a Black Lantern in the
end and now we're waiting for this big
crisis to happen in 2020 and DC when
like this entire universe of black
Lantern's is gonna show up but what you
are gonna get is limbo Lantern a
Sinestro which is an amazing concept but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the robb core if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later
whose
[Music]